[Music]
hello everyone I am Josh video and today
I'm going to be going over games from
the that were sent to us via the club's
the st. Louis classic centers Club
YouTube channel and they were sent and
if you guys want your games to be gone
over then you should send them to info
at st. Louis chess club dot-com dog so
so those are the games I'll be going
over today I had five games submitted
I'll try to go over all of them I
probably won't go over them all in their
entirety because that would take more
than the hour I have but I'll definitely
try to catch some of the key moments
that I saw in these games and maybe
suggest moments to improve and we have a
wonderful audience here who might also
suggest moves or might not so the first
game was between Rajiv Lochan and loved
Unger I do not know who these people are
but I'm just gonna be reading their
usernames so the first game was a center
counter efore d5 takes now there are two
moves as you guys might know there's
Queen takes d5 and then you usually hit
the Queen the Queen runs away life goes
on and the other line which was played
was Knight f6 because it's sometimes
nicer to not have to get your Queen out
early Knight takes d5 is coming up next
so if white wants to be real greedy
about this y can try to hold on to the
palm of the move like check and this is
a perfectly fine move I also like the
move of just grabbing the center with
something like c4
this to me is a nice move with the idea
that if a knight takes pawn you start
you can play Knight f3 first say and
then eventually you're gonna play c4 and
hit the knight
these are all fine ways to play white
played Bishop c4 which I don't think is
a terrible move either but it does allow
black to capture
upon safely but here I think that white
made a poor decision at least one I
don't really agree with so in this
position there are lots of fine moves
for example Knight f3 looks perfectly
normal you develop a piece you know
maybe black can pin you but it's not the
ends of the earth you can play h3 if
absolutely necessary you can bring your
bitter back but I don't think that
that's really gonna happen but again
this would be a normal move a move like
d4 looks completely fine even Knight c3
is probably okay so really there are
tons of good moves
but what white played was Bishop takes
d5 I move which you can't call it a
blunder because it doesn't lose material
but I really don't like it can anyone in
our wonderful audience here maybe tell
me why I don't like this move not I'm
not asking you to read my thoughts I'm
just saying why might this move not be
so great
because bishops are better than Knights
was the answer I would in open positions
I would say this is normally true but
you have to judge this because a lot of
the times your Bishop is just not doing
much but here the problem I'm agreeing
with you don't worry about it
here the bishop on c4 is actually a
great piece it's attacking this knight
it's hitting a good diagonal I would say
this is why it's good bishop in almost
all positions like this so giving it up
unprovoked because it's not like blocks
threatening anything right this Knight
is not about to take all your pieces so
giving up the bishop unprovoked I'd say
it's just not a great idea so again
nothing horrible has happened but you
can see how this actually leads to black
White's downfall you think well you're
just giving up a bishop for a knight you
shouldn't lose a game because of this
but actually white pretty much lost the
game because of this trade so in this
position why black has a threat can
anyone possibly tell me what that threat
is maybe Queen takes g2 is coming up not
a pleasant threat I would imagine so if
I were white I'd probably play Queen out
here so you offer a queen trade I know
Queen trades are boring etc etc but you
know you defuse the threat and if the
Queen moves away you can get your knight
out to you to get castled life goes on
again would I prefer blacks position
over White's probably I like the two
bishops I like the fact it's an open
position but it's not like black has
anything too special here I'd say it's
very close to equal still but instead
white played this move which is a move I
do not like
so here there's a very big problem with
this kind of position now again it's not
I wouldn't say it's losing I wouldn't
say anything awful is happening just yet
but it's the beginning of a source of
great headache for white and this
headache really basically ended the game
so black could have played Bishop out to
g4 immediately but instead chose 96
first which I like a little less but
it's also not not a bad move so white
played 93 which looks natural enough but
the Queen slides out to h5 and then
white played h3 so the idea is white
does not want this bishop to come to g4
Bishop g4 this pin is really nasty but
black found a really good move here
which I think one of you has found very
cleverly you realized h3 doesn't
actually prevent Bishop g4 and whoever
was playing black in this game loved
Unger obviously understood this also and
this is an excellent move because now
blacks threatening to just take this
Knight potentially and then white as
awful pawns and really I think that
white should just allow this to happen
like for example I think white should
take castle so now for example a move
like 94 is not so good because
the bishop now hangs not--how I should
have pointed this out immediately but
you know I'm a forgetful person but if
you take right away
you drop your book which is not a
pleasant thing but I think that actually
even after castles takes on f3 queen
takes black can play 94 you win this
pawn White's position is objectively
close to lost but you can fight on here
you're not getting checkmated you're
losing one pawn and I'd say especially
if you're playing a quick game or an
online game 1 pawn you can recover from
that and I think this would have been
the best option white instead opted for
d3 and I like how black played almost
all of this game but blacks next move I
don't like and not because it's a bad
move in any way not because this move is
awful or because it's not an improving
move black played castles Queen side and
you see it move like castles Queen side
you're like well you're improving your
position you're getting castled you're
ready to to pounce next move
so why how could this possibly be a bad
move and the reason is only that there's
a certain type of move you look for
before you play any move like castles
which is just an improving move before
improving moves you look for which type
of move can anyone in our large audience
possibly suggest something
all these people and not a single voice
this is ridiculous
someone should know what kind of move
comes before any developing move or any
just normal improving move I'm not
saying councils is a bad move I'm saying
you have a better move what kind of move
could be better than cap castles at
least suggest that what would you play
here is black mobian maybe a nicer move
since there's a horrific silence like
before a monster attacks in a movie I'm
gonna suggest night d4
you could play 95 also same thing but
you immediately putting pressure on the
night meaning that if white takes this
Bishop you snag the rook immediately and
if white doesn't what is why doing here
you're about to capture on f3 so what I
was looking for was rather than a
building move you play a temple move an
attacking move and you always look at
your attacking moves first
especially when you have your opponent
pinned up like this you have your
opponent in a vulnerable situation you
always look to punish them immediately
you don't want to have the attitude of
ah right I'll take my time I'll get a
coffee
eventually I'll punish their mistake a
lot of the times you want to punish them
quickly and immediately and I think that
again black played a really excellent
game this game but this one moment could
could have cost a little bit or at least
made it much harder to take advantage at
least in my opinion
so after 94 I don't have a good
suggestion for what I think you're just
gonna take on f3 next and it's gonna be
much similar to what happened in the
game it's just you could have forced her
to move earlier and now I think the
whites positions about to collapse I
don't see a defense here after castles
Queen side it looks like well how are
you gonna stop 94 okay you could Castle
again and get this same endgame which of
course is a pretty unpleasant endgame
don't get me wrong but again is white
just completely dead lost probably not
I'm sure white can fight on in a
position like this you can play Bishop
III for instance if takes on c2 you play
rook out would you resign this position
I wouldn't I wouldn't be happy but I
wouldn't resign I got you guys yep will
do so
but what actually can defend against
this ninety-four threat in an even
better way probably so again I challenge
our audience here how can you possibly
defend against all these threats Bishop
takes after you can't really defend
against that's kind of a tough one but
you can defend against 94 it looks
impossible right well you can do it what
piece do you need to help you you need
an assistant piece what piece can assist
this knight I would suggest using this
one so how would you do it I would go
here so the idea is that now if the
knight comes in here or goes t5 you can
drop back and say haha I'm defended now
I wouldn't be bragging in a position
like this but at the same time I think
that maybe white can survive now and
survival is not something that would
have happened if on the previous move
why did black had found 94 it would have
been immediately crushing so white got
one more chance to survive
now again white didn't happen to find
this maneuver which is understandable
it's not necessarily that easy but
sometimes if you allow your opponent one
chance back in the game
especially if you're playing a really
strong player off and you only get your
one chance if you don't get that chance
it slips away so make sure you look at
your most aggressive moves first white
played Bishop e3 and after 95 I would
say that the position is just pretty
much not savable white probably has to
even take this bishop and give up the
rook with check but obviously that's not
going to be all that fun instead white
played Queen d2 and after the very
accurate Bishop takes f3 life just was
never the same
in any case its position is just
completely busted here and black did a
pretty good job of reeling in the point
so again a really nice game by black
I'd say White's problem stemmed from
giving up this bishop for no reason on
d5 and then afterwards there was maybe
one chance to defend but after that
there wasn't a whole lot going on
so let's move on to the next one the
next game we have a London system fairly
common these days even at the top low so
fairly standard so far here there's kind
of an interesting choice black can play
Bishop d6 or Bishop e7 now white played
kind of a clever move order here notice
how white didn't develop this knight yet
why put the knight back on D - so Bishop
d6
is now a possibility but what do you
think White's idea may be maybe it
wasn't
I mean maybe white just intended to move
the bishop back or do something fairly
normal here but I think that white had a
very specific idea against this move
which was to take and then play the move
f4 so the idea is that you get a
Stonewall type setup but you're missing
your bad Bishop which is very
advantageous so next you're gonna plant
your knight out to f3 you're gonna get
castled you're gonna try to play 95 and
launch an attack so that's why white
played this sort of clever move order of
neglecting to play Knight f3 early again
it's not like this position is horrible
for black or anything like this but it's
kind of a nice trick to remember and
sometimes this is an annoying idea so
black played Bishop e7 which is
perfectly fine so now white plays Knight
f3 black castles and white plays Knight
e5 so white wants to maybe start an
attack and occasionally doing this
before you castle gives you more
attacking options black played 97 so I
don't know it's kind of a tricky
situation to judge black we could play a
normal move like taking the d7 Knight
but black instead ops - or sorry white
instead obstacle for the attack which is
nice looking I would say though that
it's it's actually very difficult to
convert any kind of attack here and the
game really got crazy very fast so black
played g6
so I don't know I would probably play my
Queen to age six here with the idea that
okay you're maybe trying h4 h5 in some
lines maybe takes on g6 so I thought the
most natural move for black was Bishop
f6
and the idea is that the bishop can
slide back I really don't think that
there's any huge attack here to be
honest I think that Black has things
pretty well taken care of but at the
same time I mean White has options maybe
you could try grabbing the C pawn at
some point the position is still
relatively normal I would say but you
have to be a little careful because this
Queen sometimes ends up really out of
play white played Queen g4 which I also
was I was very skeptical about because I
just don't I'm kind of nervous with the
Queen lining up with this Bishop and all
that so Knight takes e5 D takes e5 was
what I expected from black and I think
that black is a really really nice move
here which is a typical move in this
kind of position so hmm I thought I
heard a murmur
any ideas for people who haven't looked
at the left side of the screen
d4 I'm not so sure about because I mean
I'm not first of all I'm not sure
exactly what you're threatening like I
guess you're gonna take and then this
bishops not so good so the problem is
that I can probably take and now let's
see I don't know you maybe have some
counterplay here I thought I could just
play c4 and kind of lock you out but
maybe you have night before I don't know
d4 is actually an interesting I actually
really liked f5 myself which is very
typical because again you're basically
making it so h4 h5 does absolutely
nothing and this Queen now is attacked
if you take on f6 you let my bishop out
my rooks very strong all of a sudden you
have to worry about a 5 so for example
if so if takes then Bishop takes now e5
is a strong threat taking on g6 does
nothing because the bishop can drop back
after you take the bishop I think this
is just a nice position and if the Queen
goes back you have to worry about g5 all
the time and this Bishop might end up
kind of sad for example after Queen g3
one possibility is to play Bishop h4 and
then g5 which looks kind of crazy but
this Bishop now has some problems and
there's a really funny idea here which
is that if you play Bishop g3 which
seems to take care of everything you can
actually grab this pawn now because if
you play Bishop takes Knight I play g4 I
told you this Queen would feel some heat
so anyway it's kind of a funny line but
this didn't happen white/black took
which again is not unreasonable but I
didn't like it quite as much and again I
would probably take on take on e5 and at
least finish my development so something
like takes on e5 Knight c5 Bishop d7 and
again you you finish your development
probably this attacks not going to be
that strong I think blacks should be
doing fine
black played Bishop f6 which I liked a
little bit less but it's still not not a
terrible move white plays Knight df3 to
try to support this knight black plays
back and now probably white should kind
of lay off a little bit maybe play a
move like Queen g3 or take the d7 Queen
g3 and say well my pieces are a little
bit better I still have h4 h5 but black
white was in an aggressive move which I
understand supposedly this was a rated
classical game so these guys were
sitting down playing playing a little
bit slower so there's more time but even
so even if it weren't a blitz game even
if it's a slow game I'd be like all
right I want to attack h4 let's go but
here I think that black found and black
was Sam the beast 666 which you could
imagine he's in a very aggressive player
but in this case he finds a really
really nice defensive maneuver so again
for those of you who want to take a stab
what defensive maneuver can black play
I'll give you a little hint if black
would like to play and move like f6 here
but there are real problems first of all
I might just okay first of all I take
this palm of check this is the pick
problem and then after there I just
played a knight f7 check and you're just
losing everything I could also take here
I could also take here I have h5 coming
this move is just complete failure but
really if you can't ever move this pawn
you're just gonna get crushed with this
attack with h5 right h5 you're gonna
take open up the H file it's gonna be
sayonara so you need a way to get an f6
while also hindering this H pawn while
also defending the e6 pawn making making
things possible so what could you do
try to think like Sam the be 666
mm-hm and then after queen h3 still
trying to play h5 on you at some point
it might be a pawn sack now but it still
looks kind of strong
very nice yeah h5 is possible but again
it weakens the g5 square it makes things
a little bit harsher not h5 it's kind of
a weird move because at first you're
like well someone told me nights and the
rim are bad or grim or dim or something
that rhymes great I always like grim
people told me it was dim which doesn't
make sense because they're not light
bulbs but I don't know whatever people
want to do point is Knights on the rim
or not so good usually but in this case
it does something concrete by concrete I
mean specific to this situation and in
those cases sometimes you can disobey
general rules of chess if you have a
specific purpose in mind or a specific
idea and this Knight does a great job of
blocking this pawn it attacks the bishop
so it's a temple move which again as
I've mentioned always get the priority
so black white moves back to e3 and now
black plays up six and now all of a
sudden things are not so easy so it
looked like white was just having a huge
attack but black thumb is really nice
maneuver and now
okay this Knights under attack if the e
pawn moves the Queen's gonna be under
attack the epon can go up further things
are kind of dicey so white could play
Knight takes c6 and try to play like
this and now black has a very nice move
with E 5 pinning the pawn and I'd say
the position is just a mess I honestly
have no clue what's going on maybe the
Queen moves back maybe Knight comes to
f4 but I would say it's a mess that's
all I can say I wouldn't I can't say for
sure if one side is better or not and
the game white chose something very
interesting he played Knight takes g6
this is Mac 2 2 2 4 so Knight takes g6
is a natural beat sac right you want to
you want to take it and then if pawn
takes Knight and you take here this
Knights kind of trapped now it's true
that there are moves like a 5 but even
after that there's going to be probably
a lot of attacking chances here after a
continuation like this so instead black
actually chose to play e5 immediately
which I like hitting the Queen right
away
and this is kind of an unfortunate thing
when you're playing a chess game there's
always what I'd call a thread this is
especially true of tactical variations
where there's a very specific weight
proper way for you to play there are
lots of positions which are quiet or
which you know are a little bit like
there's not as much going on where you
can choose many fine options and you can
play lots of different moves and there's
not a specific move you have to choose
but when you have a crazy tactical
position with grim Knights and hanging
Queens and hanging knights and weird
centers and kings in the center there's
usually one or two absolute best moves
you have to find and in this case white
lost the thread of the game because
white absolutely has to play a very
specific move here in order to stay in
the game
you know if black white tries to retreat
with the Queen it's just too passive
probably you can even take the knight
but even a move like a four looks kind
of annoying to me sure you can take this
rook but I just take back my knight can
escape if I need to I can take one of
your pieces it just looks like doesn't
look very good to me so I don't want to
retreat in the game white played
something probably even worse than we're
treating which we'll get to but what
should white play here so you gotta take
care of the threat on your Queen right
and you also would rather not retreat if
not all possible because we're treating
we don't retreat here we just go forward
Bishop f5 is maybe possible but the
problem now is that I can take your
Knights and your pinned so you can't
recapture so you could take this bishop
but I think you're just going to be down
material now so this is probably not
something
and he's right
the idea is you block this and also you
keep in touch with your knight and
you're basically the thing is it's still
really complicated and really tough to
play but at least your attack still
rules so for example if H takes g6 you
take with the Bishop Knight f4 because
the knight was trapped
you take play h5 you can at least still
attack and yes blacks up a piece but you
have two pawns for it next you're
probably gonna play Knight h4 slide your
queen back play Knight f5 maybe Bishop
f5 even Bishop h7 checks in the air I
would at least say that white is pretty
good chances to be okay here I don't I
want to say why it's better or White's
mating because I don't think that's the
case but I think that white is certainly
in the game
and this is what was required so again
when you following kind of the threat of
a game you have to make sure that you
continue to follow that thread that you
play the only moves and find the only
moves if you have them because
oftentimes all you have to do is make
one mistake and then the game's over
because what white did was white took
the rook on f8 here and then the problem
was after takes Queen you just don't
have enough compensation it's just a
queen so after rook takes h3 Queen takes
f8 why was pretty much lost it wasn't I
wouldn't say it was entirely smooth
there was a couple periods at the end of
the game where things could have been
not so easy but in the end black black
definitely won and it was just the Queen
was a little bit too much and the attack
was too great so let's move on to the
next game I want to try to get through
all of them or at least most of them if
possible so can't necessarily go over
all the games in their entirety so this
game was kind of a an unusual game I
would say the start of the game itself
is really cool so e for Knight of 6 is
between NN which I assume is basically
anonymous who knows
and Stefan yawning so 93 d5e five so
here there are quite a few options but
black plays d4 yeah and again like this
is this is actually a line this 93 thing
a lot of people will play e5 which is
the main move but 93 d5 is actually
another line I think usually white takes
but II 5 d4 is kind of an entertaining
way to start the game then Knight you
see e2 and then h e4 it's already the
game's kind of interesting which I like
I don't know I mean you're kind of off
on your own you're doing your own thing
and you don't have to you know you get
just an interesting position right off
the bat so it's kind of a cool thing but
you also have to be careful when things
like this happen because it's very easy
to play badly with either color in this
position and it's very important that
you for example if you're white make
sure you don't give up this pawn easy to
do if you're black make sure you don't
give up this pawn these things sound
obvious but you have to make sure that
like don't make sure this Knight doesn't
get trapped make sure white actually
develops the kingside and doesn't just
leave pieces like this there are so many
ways to go wrong in a position this
weird so you have to make sure that you
follow your chest rules at some point
and get your pieces out and keep your
stuff defendant so f4 c5 here white
plays the move I don't care for which is
d3
there are plenty of fine options Knight
f3 and h3 chasing the night away would
kind of be mine
I think computer wanted a3 which to me
looks random but I guess they want to
shoot for before but again I you know I
turned it on mostly for amusement value
in any case white played d3 so any
guesses as to why I wouldn't like this
move again not asking you to mind-read
asking you why this move might have a
drawback III square exactly
and when there's a night here which
doesn't have many moves you don't want
to give it an additional move right so I
know it looks nice because you're
developing your bishop but and I'm not
saying blacks should play Knight here
immediately if you try a knight here
immediately take stakes here you just
lose your pawn that didn't accomplish
anything but this move is always in the
air and to me that makes things annoying
like why would you allow this if you
don't have to so there was no like
neither side really took advantage of it
at for the moment black played six so I
think why could even take this pawn now
but then black could either take this
pawn or maybe if they're really insane
take this pawn I don't know
this would be kind of a funny way to
play though right I don't know what's I
don't want to claim to know what's going
on here
you could take on e6 but now I check you
here and you're gonna be kind of sorry
I wouldn't recommend playing this way
this could get really fun though you
take on e6 and if that comes out to have
three you pin again look at this this is
amazing I'm gonna create my own game
like this okay unfortunately that didn't
happen Knight g3 who's played that at
age six because the knight was attacked
by the Queen you don't to miss that that
would be unfortunate Knight f3 there
should be seven so I want to skip ahead
to this moment
so here black played 97 which to me look
like a weird move I thought that I would
come out to c6 which looks natural keeps
the bishop open maybe you can play b5
Bishop e7 at a later time but again I
like developing the natural squares that
control the center as much as possible
it's one of my nasty features black
played a 97 which again not as some
horrible move but I'd say that it's kind
of weird to have deny blocking and I
really want to control this square in
case white tries to undermine my center
so but again nothing horrible so far
Bishop d2 Knight b6
so I would think about c4 just to keep
the white the the night out of d5 but
white played a three following computer
advice apparently but again this move
looks a little weird to me I don't know
just just like I would Castle maybe or
play C four or something like this but
okay a three is nothing horrible ninety
four ninety five brother so again I
would play c4 but white played a
harmless looking move they played
castles and this is one of those moments
where I'd say it was kind of like mutual
blindness because it was a moment where
both like black could have done
something pretty strong and didn't see
it and white white didn't also didn't
see that white black could do this so it
was kind of like both sides missed a
chance and the game continued as normal
because neither side played it but here
I think black is a really nice move and
it's based on much of what I've been
talking about which basically means I
expect you guys to see it well so what
move my black play that would be
annoying yeah
all of a sudden you're coming into e3 I
told you you'd regret d3 people don't
believe me when I say these things but
you know you regret this move now
because then if a knight lands on e3
that's gonna be super annoying right
like sure you're not gonna lose material
maybe this will happen but is this
Knight really something you want to live
with I mean keep in mind this night was
gonna end up on h6 probably the worst
square the light was on h6 rather I'm
probably the worst square possible and
now it's on e3 like in your face
basically this does not look like
something I want to do not to mention f4
is hanging here I could just take this
pawn and again you could give up a
bishop for a knight but I think black is
a great position here so again it's not
like after Knight g4 I take off over
time to resign but allowing a 9 to e3 is
something I would not want to do and
again it's why I would play this move
right away because maybe white black
could try this but the problem is that
this pawn is probably just a little too
weak now so I could win this pawn at
some point very soon but again even this
it's like it was a little too late I
would have played c4 not allowed 95 so
this whole 97 to b6 to g5 maneuver which
is kind of slow ended up being strong or
should have been strong because of
there's one little moment so you have to
make sure that you spot these these
things because again in a game
especially you're playing a strong
opponent you're not gonna get many
chances so you gotta take advantage when
you can so in the game this happens life
went on yeah so here white could have
played c4 which I thought was a strong
move with the idea that now if the
knight moves for example you can say ha
I'm pinning you and this is actually an
annoying pin because if you move your
queen I might grab this pawn at some
points if you don't on pain like my take
and again I'm threatening a pawn you
could play a move like a six but even if
I just play like rook be one like this
Knight is is really sad I'm sorry I
don't mean to make fun of it but it's
just not a good piece so
it yeah I'd actually said this one's
worse because this one's pinned and it
has no moves this one maybe has a move
it's also sad though I'm not I'm not
claiming that Iron Age six it's a
wonderful piece but I would say that
these Knights are just not so great so I
don't know I would ever like see four
white played d4 and again it came to
this moment where it was really like the
the game got lost pretty quickly so here
black could have played oh sorry black
played Queen c8 which is a move I like
and again I think that who is more of a
potential for attack at the moment I
would say it's white so I would try to
keep the Queens on with a move like
Queen d3 Queen h5 I didn't like as much
for some reason but I think it may have
to do with the fact that after takes
takes the Queen comes into c2 and comes
back this Queen is a really strong piece
it turns out because it just kills any
attacking chances but if you go to d3 it
looks a little unnatural but um but I
don't know Queen takes c8 rookie takes
c8 and then again I feel like White has
to be very careful because even though
White has this nice looking Center it's
it's kind of difficult because this
rooks are ready to come in after pawn
takes pawn this pawn is kind of a
weakness this guy's a bit of a weakness
so I'd say that actually White is the
one who has to be very careful and also
at the beginning of the game we were
making fun of blacks pieces but look at
them now
bishops here are really nice this Knight
is good this looks good this rooks gonna
come out black has nothing to complain
about so I think that white had to be
really careful try and move like c4
which again looks kind of crazy but the
idea is that after takes you have a
really nice in-between move if you take
immediately and I take you're gonna end
up giving up the two bishops and I think
something like this would be so the
bishops attacked you can't just
recapture and I think an endgame like
this the with the bishops in a wide-open
position you're gonna suffer really
badly I can tell you from personal
experience
not do it it's just bad this guy's weak
this guy's weak this might not even be
take a bowl sometimes cuz a pins just
don't do it trust me I'm a doctor
so in this position white has a nice
in-between move to at least keep things
interesting and what you're gonna find
instantly not instantly so what kind of
moves do you want to look for in a
position like this a building move is
that right that's not a building move or
that's a capture but the problem with it
is that I take back with check and I
don't think you've achieved much you
have to move I could push my pawn this
doesn't look fun plus I'm down a pond
what's going on what did you do look
what you did no easy to do easy to do
look for temple moves attacking moves
we've talked about this a little bit you
have to try to threaten your opponent
otherwise they're just gonna kind of
roll all over you in a position like
this you can and I like your spirit
because you're trying to do stuff the
problem is I don't know if there's a
huge threat for example after I take
you've given away another pawn right if
you try a 95 I might play here hitting
your Bishop I might take here next the
problem is you're trying to activate but
you're not making concrete threats and
the problem is I'm just taking your
pumps one by one so I like that you're
trying to do something forceful I think
it's the right approach but I also think
that you're kind of given up too much
maybe you have something like e six
followed by Bishop g4 at some point but
again it's just it seems like it's gonna
be too slow I'm already attacking your
bishop you probably you have to find a
square which isn't easy every square is
covered right you have to go to the back
rank which as we know is kind of sad
yeah you don't want to have to do this
so anyway I mean I like your idea but I
think a better move is just rook happy
one so the reason I'm going this work by
the way is because this pawn needs to
stay defended if you allow if you play
the other rook than this pawn always
hangs with
I found annoying so rook FB one I think
it's better it's not an obvious move
you're moving from the F file to the B
file kind of weird but idea is this
bishops actually under attack which
obviously is nice but it doesn't have a
great move because if it just moves and
you take on c4 you're threatening main
six pawn now right so that's kind of
annoying if black tries to defend it and
you take you actually have a cool move
after pawn takes pawn Knight takes d4 is
not a cool move I'm gonna take and I'm
gonna take and nothing's cool about this
not even remotely
unfortunately aha nice
I'm not saying that life is grand all of
a sudden but okay if Luke takes rook
Bishop takes Knight is good for you
so black would probably take here and
now maybe you can play rook d7 and I
don't know but this looks kind of
annoying right
all of a sudden White's totally in the
game and actually this fork looks really
unpleasant I mean maybe you can play
rook da and force the rooks off but now
I play rook here I'm trying to come into
the back rank I don't know and again I'm
not totally sure about this but at least
it looks like you're getting counter
play it looks like you're trying
something right because what happened in
the game was what white played here and
now everything just falls off the board
Knight c3 should come and actually black
should have played 93 a few times is the
one thing I'd recommend but basically
once you're down these two pawns it's
just really tough because black is
getting the rook in the Knights coming
in just too much to deal with right so
yeah so again I'll stop here the game
continued for quite a while
white ended up blundering a piece which
made black blacks life a little easier
but the main idea is just that once you
don't find c4 once you trade to that end
game and you don't get any kind of play
you saw how quickly black just took
everything so you have to be very
careful in positions like this to always
spot those resources when you get them
if there's any central theme of all
these games it's when you have a
resource you have to find it you have to
spot it because you often don't get a
second chance so I think we've got time
for one more probably
ah yeah we'll do one more here I'll be
extra brutal so it doesn't take time so
this was get between Clyde frog and Edie
Zilber one of those sounds like a name
so he came to this opening position and
I found this kind of interesting I'm
kind of curious I'm just gonna take a
random survey it's not a political
survey so don't hang up on me you would
you guys defend this pawn or would you
push d5 right away I'm just curious
without thinking about it too much
what's your first instance how many of
you would play d5 one of you and how
many of you would play 92 what are the
rest of you plan taking this pawns bad I
hope that's not your move huh well d5
was with the first option so you should
have had your hand raised you get points
off for that anyway I would almost
certainly defend this pawn in the game
white played this Bishop e5 s may be
possible but again black really wants to
take this pawn if you have to take with
the bishop it's kind of bad even if
you're pinning this Knight for example
like just having to take what the bishop
is annoying because now I block I Castle
you have to give up one of your bishops
it's just kind of not not what you're
looking for
yeah 992 would be a pretty normal move
but the reason I like it is because you
keep the tension for one more move so if
black takes and you take you're fairly
happy here because now your bishop can
come out if this pawn comes under attack
you play f3 you just kind of have a
typical central space advantage I would
say and the problem is that black needs
a move and it's not so easy to find a
move at least a very useful normal if
the knight goes here for instance
then I can't go back to where it wants
to go it has to go to be eight or a five
if you're feeling particularly suicidal
but really black doesn't have a great
move with the night if black plays in
that f6 which looks totally natural now
you play d5 and f3 the problem is that
blacks F pawn is now blocked so in order
to play f5 which is the normal move you
have to move your knight which cost you
time and time is money so in the game
white just play d5 straight away it was
like alright charge or R but the problem
now is you get an f5 of one move so you
see how if white maybe thought a little
bit more on that one move could have
possibly saved a little bit of time in
the opening and again time can really
make a difference and ended up not
mattering in this game but I think that
again if black had played a little more
accurately that one moment might have
cost a little bit more and this is
another moment which I see all the time
so you know how I said that white
relieved the tension too early by
playing d5 rather than maintaining it
with 92 this was another moment why is
black in a rush to me to play f4 to just
immediately shut down the position first
of all your King's Indian attacks gonna
run into a real problem in this position
anyone know what that might be
there's no king if there's a king here
feel free to close the left floor and
start hurling pawns here if you play f4
which happened in the game let's say you
start playing g5 h5g for what's just
gonna laugh at you you know late let's
say all right I'm just doing I'm just
showing you this for an example you and
then I'll play I don't know I'm just
gonna play a stupid move just because I
feel like it now let's say alright
what's your next move
you have no attack here because I have
no king I can just let you push your
pawns all day you're not gonna do
anything
I might even decide to open up the board
myself because guess what your King
still here your king doesn't look so
happy now so I would say that this is
kind of bad
and again I would probably just play
night of six and say look maybe I'll
play out for one day but I might not
maybe I'll just castle maybe I'll play
maybe I'll play for c6 look the Queen
and rook on this file very unlikely but
it's at least in them in in the cards
potentially I might play a6 b5 which is
similar to what happened in the game but
the point is I keep my options open
maybe I'll even take here and then play
Knight g4 sometimes that's an idea to
look out for also the point is and one
of the main things I wanted to focus on
from the opening in this game is that
keeping the tension is often a really
good idea because then it forces your
opponent to find like to find a move
which is maybe not ideal they either
have to you know they either have to put
a piece where they don't want it play a
move prematurely commit to a plan and
then you can adjust what you're gonna do
so the main theme of this game is
commitment basically so in the game
black played here and now it just was
really hard to get counter play black
did this pawn push but the problem is it
doesn't do anything
when White has so much extra space it's
hard for black to actually generate any
threats over here like what pieces could
you possibly use these pieces are all
out of out of the Queen side right so
you're gonna have just no attack
whatsoever and this was the one the last
moment in the game I thought was
significant because to be honest after
black made this decision I think the
game was almost over so I really think
that black has to play a move like
Knight f6 and just kind of again keep
the tension keep things as they are the
key is not to allow white to open up the
kingside it looks weird cuz you think
this is your side but your Kings over
here your King has to either stay in the
center or castle so if you try to Castle
queenside you're gonna get crushed with
a four at some point because again you
just have no space over here all my
pieces are pointing at the Queen side
your King does not want to be there so
if this side of the board opens up
you're in big trouble black's only
chance is to keep this side of the word
closed and hide the king over here at
some J
juncture Kings hired its not not much I
can do about it you know they have to
they don't want to be on an open part of
the board so the key is like after so
for example I don't know if Bishop d7 h4
so now you have to watch out sometimes
for g5 h5 or something like this so you
play Knight f6 now if g5 you can put
your knight here and kind of hold the
pawns at bay
even here I don't necessarily like
blacks position but at least you're okay
because the Kings side remains sort of
closed you keep that side of the world
locked so that the king can hide here
the problem with what happened black
took here and now this side of the board
is just completely trashed white can
play a4 eventually which happened white
doesn't even have to play f4 I mean Y
can just play Bishop h3 trading these
bishops is probably a good idea start
launching missiles with with g4 even but
probably f4 is coming at some point you
just have to be careful that for cuz it
does open up this bishop but I wouldn't
say there's anything to worry about here
and again the game basically was really
downhill from here you know obviously I
could make a few comments on it but
really it's just bad so basically the
decision making with the pawns really
decided the game when white played d5 to
early it allowed black a little counter
play when white black played a four to
early it took away counter play compared
to at night f6 and once you relieve the
tension with taking on g3 the game was
basically over because again f4 is an
idea is just way too much and your King
cannot hide this King has no home and
you want to make sure that your King
eventually has a place that can hide
from various threats otherwise it'll be
tough anyway I think that's about the
time we got for this one so I hope that
this answered your questions about some
of these games and that you can find it
useful for your next online battles
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]